et de son côté la belgique suit
l'exemple de la france en instaurant un
couvre-feu pendant un mois les belges ne
pourront pas sortir de chez eux de
minuit à 5 heures du matin comptes aux
bars et restaurants ils seront
totalement fermées et les précisions de
serial ball depuis lundi en belgique
bars et restaurants ont tiré le rideau
de nouvelles mesures prises par le
gouvernement à l'issue d'une réunion de
crise pour tenter d'endiguer l'épidémie
de kovy 19,6 le premier ministre belge
souligne que cette décision vise à
éviter le pire
difficile pour les restaurateurs de
ravaler leur colère pour le secteur déjà
fragilisée par la crise sanitaire
c'est un nouveau coup dur on se sent pas
considérer et ça me fait mal au coeur je
suis vraiment désolé mais j'en peux plus
quoi mam nous serveur ou ou responsables
ou cuisiniers ou plongeurs
tout le monde souffre c'est horrible
ressemble particules dans la tristesse
pour ce milieu conquis cool et on sent
vraiment que c'est l'urgence pour c'est
très dommage je crois que on est une
grande famille on essaie de soutenir
mais là je crois vraiment que les choses
vont changer parce qu'on en a vraiment
ras le bol
énorme et ça peut plus continuer de la
colère et surtout de l'incompréhension
partagé par les habitants de bruxelles
pour eux cette décision revient à trahir
l'identité de la belgique convivial et
bonne vivante déjà et à ceux sur
problèmes sanitaires et à cette stress
psychologique économique et on sent
qu'il ya vraiment de l'attention des
gens s'énervent pour rien les gens ne
savent plus c'est quoi leur quotidien
c'est comme si on nous cacher quelque
chose dont on n'était pas au courant
quoi mais mais sans train de tuer dans
l'oeuf
un truc qui fait la belgique puisqu'elle
est aussi ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine c'est une autre culture donc
la restauration aussi un an moules
frites nos manières de cuisiner même le
boudin compote toutes ces choses là
voilà c'est la restauration qui fait la
culture les restaurants belges pourront
toutefois continuer la vente à emporter
jusqu'à 22 heures
une maigre consolation tout comme le
couvre-feu la fermeture des bars et des
restaurants doit durer un mois